hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
i see uh
all kinds of questions here
oh gosh
see one here from spaceman asking what's
the densest thing in the universe
i've heard that black holes don't count
why
all right first of all let's talk about
what is density
so density is defined as the mass per
unit volume
how much does something weigh or how
much mass is there in something in a
given volume
so for example water has a density of
one gram per cubic centimeter you have a
cubic centimeter of water a centimeter
on the side and cube and how much does
it weigh answer one gram
so other things have different densities
for example the earth has an average
density of about 5 grams per cubic
centimeter
the uh i think mercury has a density of
13.6 grams per cc i think this is a good
thing to ask for from alpha
the densest uh element
is uh well it's it's always a
competition between iridium and osmium
uh it depends because what determines
the density well you've got certain
atoms you've got iridium atoms osmium
atoms and the question is how are they
packed in
and one question is what crystal
structure do they form and how do they
get packed together how many osmium
atoms fit in a given in a cubic
centimeter and so that's one question
uh those two i think are around 18 grams
per cc if i remember correctly
the other thing that's a very subtle
issue
is the isotopic abundances of uh in
osmium and iridium
and
the issue there is
when you have
an iridium atom for example
how much the iridium atom
weighs on its own
depends on how many protons and neutrons
it has in its nucleus and what
determines the atom to be an iridium
atom
is that it has what is it 79 no that's
gold oh gosh
70 something sorry don't remember 75-ish
protons
in its nucleus
and that's what as soon as it has 75
let's say protons in nucleus then it is
iridium
but
there's also a question of how many
neutrons does it have
and nuclei tend to have a few more
neutrons than protons in their stable
form but there are different forms of
iridium different isotopes of iridium
that have different numbers of neutrons
and so that
those different isotopes each iridium
atom has a different mass because each
proton weighs a certain amount each
neutron weighs a certain amount so you
have an isotope with more neutrons it
will weigh more okay so this is a subtle
thing because if you say i've got a i've
got a bucket full of iridium very heavy
a bucket full of iridium but i've got a
bucket full of iridium or a bucket full
of osmium
the question is what are the isotopic
abundances in that bucket
so
if there was just one isotope that was
stable
then
you wouldn't have to ask this question
but even for hydrogen for example
there's standard protiums uh hydrogen
isotope whether it's just a prot a
proton and nucleus and an electron and
there's also deuterium for hydrogen
which has a proton and a neutron in the
nucleus
and
the the density of water for example uh
is
its standard density if you have the
standard ratio of the amount of
deuterium
to
protein in the hydrogen atoms and water
but if you have heavy water for example
heavy water is water in which which is
d2o instead of an ordinary hydrogen
hydrogen is the only one of the elements
where there's sort of a different symbol
for a different isotope but in the case
of hydrogen if you have deuterium
instead of hydrogen in the water the
density of the resulting water will be
different
and uh um
and so it is with iridium and osmium uh
in in if you have different
number if you have the different
isotopes of really amino acids they each
have about ten
five to ten stable isotopes um and the
relative abundances of those different
isotopes will determine the overall
density of the sample of rhodium or osmo
okay so if you just get a
a bunch of radiomarasmium
what the relative abundances of those
isotopes will be depends on for example
what mine you mined the thing from in
some mines in colorado or something
there'll be a different isotopic
abundance than a mine in kazakhstan or
wherever else
and and why are there different isotopic
abundances presumably because when the
earth was still molten and all these
materials were kind of flowing around
details of the particular currents and
details of the particular uh conditions
would determine the separation of these
uh uh of these isotopes
that
um that they would end up with more in
this place and less in that place so so
anyway that that's a that was a little
bit of a footnote here but the the for
the elements those are the most uh those
are the densest elements but you know
you say which one is denser well it
depends on what mind you you mind it
from
um so then
there are
uh then we can start asking about things
other than
things made of atoms so things made of
ordinary atoms we can say the highest
densities for elements at least are
things like iridium and osmium um
we could ask about i'm not sure for
other materials i'm not sure we know
what the densest material that is the
thing whose molecules kind of line up in
just such a way that we can just pack
more molecules in to a given volume i'm
not sure we know what the densest
material is um in that in that regard it
certainly must be a densest known one i
don't know what it is
um
the i would guess that the elements were
actually up there in terms of density
because it's it's a good
when by the time you take those atoms
and
they have a certain size and you're
packing them all together that's going
to tend to lead to the highest density
thing i think although one could imagine
that you've these atoms are if you think
of them as little spheres if you imagine
having a you know a ball pit full of
spheres
you'll realize that the spheres don't
fit perfectly together like for example
if you had a thing made of cubes you
could imagine if all the cubes are the
same size you could just build this this
giant uh you know sort of uh
brick of cubes where all the cubes fit
precisely together without any gaps
between them and and that will be a
denser packing of cubes for spheres the
densest packing is the so-called kepler
packing kind of packing that people tend
to use for spherical fruit in grocery
stores like oranges and things like this
um they'll tend to pack them in this
particular way if you just throw spheres
together they tend not to arrange
themselves in that packing even if you
stretch them together they'll tend to
always have uh have um have voids that
you don't you don't get to squash out
it's different from two dimensions in
two dimensions we have a bunch of coins
on a table and you scrunch them together
they'll always arrange themselves in
this hexagonal pattern but any case the
the question of of what uh you know what
is the densest packing
of molecules well i could imagine even
if you have things which are basically
spheres like atoms you can approximate
that way if there are little little
holes between the spheres and if there
was something else that fit into those
holes then you would have a denser
packing
um and uh that's kind of what when you
have uh with circles the so-called
apollonian packings where you have a
packing of circles like you have a
hexagonal array of circles and then in
the intestines in the little areas
between the circles where you have like
let's say uh you know four circles
coming together and there's a little
thing those those figures used to be
called in babylonian times they were
called uh well
the um translation from whatever acadian
or whatever it is was kind of the ox's
nose it was kind of a thing that was was
sort of a a cusp thing with a bunch of
cusps that was the the gap left between
four spheres for example
but but you can imagine in the case of
these packings actually there's only
three spheres coming together in a
hexagonal packing but you can imagine in
that little area you know if you had a
small enough circle i should have said
circle not sphere if you had a small
enough circle you could fit an extra
circle in there same thing with in three
dimensions in the standard kepler
packing if you have the oranges and then
you have some very tiny
kind of micro oranges or some other kind
of fruit that just fits in those little
intestines and those little gaps you
could make a denser packet so i don't
know what what um what you can do with
that with with ordinary molecules but
then if we take go out of the domain of
kind of things you can make materials
you can just mine out of the ground so
to speak as ordinary matter and we ask
about other kinds of things and what
their densities are
well the highest density common kind of
thing
is
an atomic nucleus
and
in the in the universe
there are examples of extremely big
atomic nuclei and those are neutron
stars
and so some stars
um not our sun but stars a bit bigger
than our sun
um will
uh after they they end up uh burning up
all of their kind of uh fuel that's sort
of nuclear fuel
they'll contract down
and they will become neutron stars and
so the sun would end up something that
bigger than the sun would end up being
maybe 10 kilometers across
and it will be just full of neutrons
and
it would have the density of an atomic
nucleus but it's a big nucleus it's a
nucleus 10 kilometers across rather than
a nucleus um 10 minus 50 meters a
thousand trillionth of a meter across
um which is the size of an ordinary
atomic nuclear well the atomic nucleus
may be ten times that size for a big big
nucleus that's the size for a single
proton
um
but so the um the sort of the the most
obviously dense things
uh in the universe are neutron stars
which have a density of 100 trillion
grams per cc
so water is 1 gram per cc neutron star
is 100 trillion grams per cc
neutron stars are very weird things
they um
uh they they have a crust actually
neutron star has a crust of iron 56
um which is why iron iron56 it's because
of chemical elements the nuclei of uh
small nuclei uh kind of
uh
they
they are less tightly bound
than bigger nuclei and very big nuclei
are less tightly bound than somewhat
smaller nuclei and so the place in the
middle that has sort of the highest
binding
is an isotope of iron ion 56
and so the way that a neutron star is
formed it will end up with sort of a
coating of that i think on its surface
um
inside the neutron star people don't
completely know what it's like inside a
neutron star
and to what extent there are neutrons
just packed together and to what extent
the neutrons have been so sort of
crushed that the corks and gluons that
are inside the neutrons are kind of
free-flowing and making kind of a port
blue on plasma rather than there being
individual neutrons packed together in
the neutron star and it's also the case
that you get other kinds of exotic
things like other kinds of
hyperons and so on which are uh kind of
things that involve not just the up and
down quarks that make up neutrons and
protons but also the strange quarks that
makes up things like lambda particles
sigma particles and so on these are
things which if they were kind of left
to their own devices
in
in uh as a separated object like a
lambda particle decays
with a
lifetime of a 100 uh
100 millionth of a second
um i think if i my memory serves right
um
but
when it is embedded
in a um inside like a neutron star it
can just sit there forever it's kind of
the same thing as the neutron if you
have a separated neutron a separated
neutron will decay in about 15 minutes
into a proton an electron and an
anti-neutrino
but neutrons bound inside nuclei don't
have they they are they're kind of
prevented from decaying but because
the the the kind of the energy budget
that they need for that decay
the total mass of a proton electron and
anti-neutrino
is a little bit less than the mass of a
free neutron
but when a neutron is bound inside a
nucleus there is binding energy that
reduces the effective mass of the
neutron and makes its effective mass be
lower than the mass of the proton
electron neutrino and so that bound
neutron can't decay into a proton
electron neutrino at least it can't
usually decay some of the instabilities
some of the radioactivity and some
elements is the result of neutrons
effectively decaying because they're not
tightly enough bound inside nuclei but
usually in a nucleus a a neutron is
bound to the point where it doesn't it's
not energetically possible for it to
decay but if you can get a free neutron
this wasn't known that people didn't do
this until the 1930s to get it sort of a
free neutron if you can get a free
neutron just on its own
it decays in about 15 minutes
so okay
so the densest kind of ordinary things
out there are neutron stars
uh they have a weird structure um but uh
they're you know they're very very
perfectly spherical they have very you
know quite high gravity and a mountain
you know what on earth you could have
mount everest that's you know whatever
it is six miles five miles high or
something um
the uh
uh for a neutron star a mountain is
something a tiny fraction of a
millimeter high and neutron star is
otherwise a perfect sphere because the
gravity of a neutron star and the the
way that the sort of the the flexibility
of the sort of assemblage of neutrons is
such that just gets pulled in like a
water drop a water drop in well if you
don't worry about air resistance and
gravity and things like that a water
drop would be a sphere it's pulled
together by the surface tension of water
make it
uh assemble itself into something which
has the minimum surface area it's the
same thing with neutron stars neutron
stars are pretty precise spheres
uh the nearest neutron star to us we
don't have one completely in our
backyard i think the the crowd nebula is
probably the nearest one that's known
that was a
star that exploded in 1054 a.d and left
over this this um this nebula of gas
that you can kind of see through a
telescope and the center of that is a
neutron star um that is also in fact a
spinning neutron star that is a pulsar
it sends out a pulse of radio energy um
sort of one side of the neutron star
it's not symmetrical and one side of it
is uh is emitting um uh
radio energy and so every time the
neutron star rotates and it rotates
rapidly um i don't remember how fast
that one rapper rotates a few times a
second i think
um the uh
yeah i think that's about right it's
like yeah it's a few times a second um
the um
uh it you you get to kind of uh detect
that radio signal
it's of course very remarkable you can
have a thing 10 kilometers of bus that
rotates a few times a second that's a
that's a sort of remarkable um um
[Music]
sort of remarkable feature of something
that has that density it's able to
rotate at that speed by the way i should
say that the i don't exactly know how
much
yeah there is just like the earth bulges
a bit at the equator i i guess neutron
stars also bulge at their equator
although i don't know the trade-off
between the the amount of gravity and um
the amount of uh that you get from sort
of the centrifugal force of the thing
spinning around i don't know i'd have to
probably work that out um to to really
work that out
you need to know essentially the
viscosity of neutron matter
just like water kind of flows and you
know something like uh uh syrup prequel
in british english uh is you know you
pour it and it flows very very slowly
that's because it has a higher viscosity
um it it has a higher tendency to
even out stresses inside the material um
and and other things have have lower
viscosity inside a neutron star neutron
star is a superfluid which means that it
actually has zero viscosity with respect
to certain kinds of things and i don't
know how exactly that works out in terms
of the deformation of a neutron star
okay but other things and are there
things that are dense to the neutron
stars well
there's a thing which in some sense is
denser than a neutron star and that's a
black hole
well in a black hole what's happened the
star significantly bigger than the sun
will eventually when it when it uh sort
of
has used up all its fuel and it has a
supernova in it it
uh blows everything off and then it sort
of what's left contracts down
um if it's bigger than i think one and a
half times the mass of the sun
it will um
right yeah i think that's right um it
will um
it will form a black hole
now what's confusing about black holes
is
that
in a black hole
the
what's happened is there's so much
gravity that even light can't escape
on the earth you shoot something up
at more than 25 000 miles an hour it
will escape from the gravity of the
earth for the sun it's 100 000 miles an
hour different
sizes and masses of objects will have
different escape velocities when there's
something sufficiently small with
sufficiently great mass
the escape velocity will be more than
the speed of light and that means that
you don't get to see
nothing escapes from a black hole at
least in the first approximation
so that means that outside a black hole
you've got all this mass
inside the black hole and you've got um
an outside it nothing is escaping
the only thing that is sort of quotes
escapes is the force of gravity that's
associated with that mass so outside of
the black hole it is exerting a force of
gravity on other things around it so if
there's something in orbit around that
black hole black hole behave as if it
has the mass that corresponds to the
black hole so one thing you can do is to
say well let's work out the effective
density of the black hole let's take the
mass of the black hole and divide it by
the volume of what's inside the event
horizon of the black hole inside the
region where light can't escape from the
black hole
well that's a reasonable thing to do to
think about density but really if you
say what's inside black hole just get me
some black hole stuff that's inside the
black hole that doesn't really make any
sense to ask about that first of all you
can't get stuff from inside the event
horizon to outside the event horizon
just as light can't escape nothing can
escape from inside the event horizon so
if we say let's go mining you know
forget the iridium and osmium let's or
even neutron star matter let's just get
some a piece of black hole matter that
will be you know more massive than we
can imagine well no it doesn't work that
way you can't put your shovel into the
black hole and bring something back your
your shovel uh what would actually
happen is your shovel would get pulled
into the inside of the black hole and
eventually would uh would end up kind of
crushed at the center of the black hole
now the thing that's really confusing is
that the way that the theory of black
holes works
it has to do with the effect of gravity
is a deformation of space time that's
that's how the the the curvature of
space is what determines the force of
gravity and that's a way to think about
what the what gravity is due to
is if you imagine you've got a sort of a
flat sheet or something and you're
shooting a a a ball across this it's a
billiard table let's say then you're
shooting the billiards across the table
and you they go in a straight line if
you're if they're going to go they the
the the shortest path across the table
is just a straight line but now imagine
you have a billiard table that's
deformed that has a that has uh sort of
a a a big um uh hollow in its basement
and now imagine shooting this billy ball
well it will no longer go in a straight
line it will go in it will it's it's its
path will be deflected and that's kind
of the way that one thinks about the
source of gravity in in general
relativity and actually also in our
models of physics although it's a little
bit more granular you can see what
happens a little bit more in detail in
our models of physics
but
uh in basically what's happening is you
can think about this sort of defamation
of space time
so so that's kind of the way that one
understands the effect of of of gravity
on space and a black hole has that
effect on space that it deforms space in
this way
but
really when you're looking outside a
black hole all you know is the
deformation of space outside the black
hole what's happening inside the black
hole is kind of none of your business
it's inside an event horizon you'll
never be able to communicate with it who
knows what's going on inside that black
hole
and the sort of dirty secret of black
holes is that actually maybe that almost
nothing is going on inside the black
hole the whole of the black hole may be
empty except one little tiny
infinitesimal dot in the middle
which is a singularity in space time
where essentially the curvature of space
is infinite
and sort of all the quotes mass of the
black hole is concentrated right at that
point at the center of the black hole it
could be that way it could also be that
there's a crushed star and lots of
planets and all kinds of things inside
the black hole it doesn't matter because
outside the event horizon all that
matters is the total mass inside the
black hole
so this question of sort of what's
inside a black hole describe what's
inside a black hole is something that is
is really sort of out of the domain of
what you need to talk about in the
traditional theory of gravity
in in our models of physics we can start
to talk a little bit more about what's
inside a black hole and we can talk a
little bit more about what it means
for one to reach that singularity in the
in the traditional theory of gravity one
thinks of space as this continuous thing
and so if there's a place where the
curvature becomes infinite what is that
like it's kind of like you have this
sheet and somewhere the curvature of the
sheet becomes infinite well what is that
really like it's like you poke a hole
you just cut a hole in that sheet
well in our models of physics where in
the end at the very lowest levels at a
very small scale the structure of space
is not continuous like that it's made of
discrete points connected in some giant
network we don't get to say oh there's
just a hole there we don't know what
happens there it's just a hole in
space-time we have to explicitly
represent that whole
in terms of different uh different
pattern of connections between the the
atoms of space of the speak
um and so we get to have a much more
explicit representation of that and we
don't get to just sort of wimp out and
say oh well it's a hole so to speak
but so this question about what's the
density of stuff
in the traditional model of gravity you
would say well there's an effective
density for the whole black hole but
there's no sort of actual thing you can
pull out that has that density but if
you look within the black hole as sort
of you can think of it's just this
infinite density at the very center of
that hole that's one possibility there
are other possibilities as well but it's
kind of a messy not very well defined
thing
so in our model it's an interesting
question whether we could get a little
bit more precise about what the density
ends up being because in our model
the there's this whole network that
represents space
very small scale maybe 10 to the minus
100 meters a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillionth of a meter
across if i got the right number of
trillions
um
the uh
that's sort of the the effective
distance between the atoms of space that
make up this thing that we perceive as
continuous space just like we perceive a
fluid like water as a continuous thing
even though it's made of molecules same
story with space
now the the notion of mass or energy
is
associated with the density of activity
in that network so the network is
continually getting rewritten it's
continually rearranging itself and the
density of that rearrangement
is what corresponds to mass or energy in
our models so an interesting question is
whether
one could do a better job of saying well
just how much mass is there in this
volume of space in our models i think
the answer is probably yes one could do
a better job and one could answer this
question a little bit more precisely
about sort of what happens when you end
up with with high mass and for example
is it possible to have actually a good
question is it possible to have a
configuration in which the average
density of a region
uh no i guess it isn't i guess we know
it isn't i was going to say in which the
average density of a region is larger
than something there's there's a limit
within a given volume the if the amount
of mass within a given volume exceeds
some value
that
will necessarily
evolve into a black hole it may not
immediately be a black hole but it will
turn into a black hole these are the
so-called singularity theorems of
general relativity that basically say
whenever you have too much mass in a
given volume it will eventually collapse
into a black hole with an event horizon
and so on
so anyway that's a little bit on on
uh what are the densest things in in the
universe
um
richard is commenting that the entire
mass of the earth a neutron star density
would fit in a 300 meter diameter sphere
which is the size he says of the arecibo
radio telescope that's interesting you
know that's exactly the kind of thing
that you should be able you can just
type into wolfman alpha and um
orphanalpha.com just go there and just
say
mass of the earth at neutron star
density and it should be able to tell
you these these things i have to say the
arecibo radio telescope i never had a
chance to see it i always wanted to see
it was a big so radio telescope is um uh
the the way it works it's a it's a like
a big radio that well there's different
kinds but the simplest kind is like a
big radio dish a big radio antenna and
those radio antennas what how does the
radio antenna work well there's radio
waves coming in and you have something
which is kind of a metal thing which
will reflect radio waves and you arrange
to reflect them in a para you have a
paraboloid you have something that's
like a parabola like an x y equals x
squared type curve and you rotate that
around so you get this paraboloid so
it's a so it's a it's just a kind of a
bowl shaped thing and that particular
mathematical figure has the property
that when you have a bunch of uh rays
coming in from infinity all parallel
like bunch of radio waves coming in from
infinity all parallel that wherever they
hit on this paraboloid they will be
reflected in such a way that they will
always uh reach
the same point in the middle the focal
point of the paraboloid and so if you
have this paraboloid you'll you'll be
able to take all this radio energy
that's coming in anywhere in the in the
uh on this on this you know sort of
circular uh
region
and um anywhere on that in that disk
disc
anything that re that hits in anywhere
on that disc will be reflected by the
antenna and will will always reach will
always cross over at the focal point and
so at the focal point you have a
detector and that means that all that
radio energy that's coming that that
arrives anywhere on the disc you can
detect because it's concentrated at the
point of the focal point and so you can
detect it with your with your radio
detector
well so the question is how do you build
a really big radio telescope
and the thing that was done in puerto
rico in arecibo was somebody said
there's a mountain that's has roughly
the shape of a radio telescope bowl all
we have to do is hang pieces of radio
telescope from different places in this
in this sort of basin between mountains
and we've got a radio telescope and
that's what they did it was done in the
1960s i think
and um it was kind of made of this sort
of wire mesh type material and it had a
lot of things where you were sort of
hanging
pieces of it uh in this in this sort of
naturally formed basin
and um
the uh i know they had all kinds of
trouble with with all sorts of very
natural things about birds and bird
droppings and all sorts of things like
that
um and i i think it was a place and one
could imagine what would have trouble
with wind and so on but i think it was a
mesh so the wind would just go through
it but unfortunately
in um
uh what was it two three years ago now
unfortunately some wires broke and the
telescope just collapsed it's a real
really big shame
and um that that had been the biggest
sort of single dish
radio telescope in the world
um there's another one being built i
gather in china
um
the
uh
that's that's one kind of radio
telescope there's a there's different
kinds of radio telescopes so
another one is to have many dishes
the so-called vlad the very large array
and secure new mexico is of that type
and there are other ones in other places
i think there's one in
chile um
that is
what happens there is that instead of
instead of collecting all the radio
energy at one time what you do is you
have these these individual antennas on
a track and railroad type track and you
kind of you're kind of collecting things
but you you move them up and down the
track
um and you kind of try and synthesize
the kind of the what you would have got
from from having that single dish more
or less
and there are other approaches that are
uh use interferometry can talk about
that another time people are interested
um
let's
see uh
oh gosh lots of questions apparently
about things like white holes
yeah well white holes
we pretty good idea that black holes
exist in fact there's a there's yet
there's another kind of thing that was
in the news last day or so from our
friends at the event horizon telescope
um
that uh is a sort of a somewhat an image
of the black hole that's at the center
of our galaxy the giant garbage
collector at the center of our galaxy
that's right now about a hundred
thousand times the mass of the sun and
we'll gradually kind of um uh consume a
bunch of stars in our galaxy um
the uh the picture it has a definite
orange glow i think the orange is kind
of a fake um but uh uh the the main
point is there's there's light there's
radio energy coming from the the sort of
outside of this area in the very center
where there's nothing coming out and
that's kind of the sign that there's a
black hole there there's stuff outside
it but there isn't stuff right at the
black hole and there tend to be rather
intense emissions around a black hole
because what happens is
things when you have a black hole things
there'll be an accretion disk formed
there'll be something where things are
falling into the black hole how does
something fall into a black hole well it
doesn't usually just go straight in
you know if it had it as soon as it has
any motion that isn't kind of just in
the direction towards the center of the
black hole it will tend to be to spiral
into the black hole it will tend to be
sort of in an orbit around the black
hole it's gradually getting sucked into
the black hole as it loses energy and
and sort of like a satellite um decaying
in its orbit uh
around the earth it decays in its orbit
because it it it uh gets some resistance
to motion usually from from some air in
the in the sort of wisps of atmosphere
so to speak
um and uh
and so it is with things around black
holes but they they will lose energy in
other ways um and in particular what
will happen is as they spiral in faster
and faster and faster they will um they
will
that the spiraling process will cause
them to lose energy to emit energy
basically there's a rule
in electromagnetism that any accelerated
charge emits radiation
so emits electromagnetic radiation so
that that's how radio fundamentally
works you take a charge like an electron
and it's in a wire and you are with a
voltage you're making an electron go
oops going that way on the wire you
reverse the voltage up it goes down on
the wire reverse the voltage goes up in
the wire and so on and so a radio
antenna like the one you'll find in a
phone
is basically every like a billion times
a second it's reversing the voltage it's
making electrons go one way the other
way one way the other way etc
and what happens is it's just a
fundamental fact about electromagnetism
that when you accelerate when you you
know if you if an electron was just
going up i'm just going along the
constant speed a constant velocity in a
constant direction that's all good but
as soon as you say oh turn around go
back the other way
you need to have an acceleration you
need to slow it down you need to speed
it up again that's an acceleration
and the rule is that accelerated charges
emit electromagnetic radiation and
that's that's how radio works is is by
having accelerating charges in the
antenna that emit uh emit energy and so
in order to keep something going around
in the circle you have to be
accelerating it because the only thing
that isn't accelerating is something
that's just keeping going in a straight
line
um in in flat space and um
the uh so that that will be a thing so
to keep something going in a circle you
have to accelerate it to keep it in the
circle
and it turns out that there are uh when
when you do that
following the rule that accelerated
charges radiate
the thing is producing electromagnetic
radiation particularly one one common
thing is what's called synchrotron
radiation which is a
form of radiation that's produced by
charged particles going in in circular
orbits
so so that's so what tends to happen is
around a black hole things get pulled in
faster and faster and faster they emit
more and more synchrotron radiation and
um effectively other forms of radiation
as well um and uh
so that's so it tends to be that it's
very bright you know the black hole in
the middle there's nothing there but
around it
there's something right at least in the
secretion disk of things sort of
rotating around them and whether that
accretion disk ends up being a single
plane or not is a different question i
don't know exactly how that works
in the case of in most cases i think it
does tend to end up as a single plane
because things tend to get attracted to
that plane so it's like our solar system
our solar system is more or less you
know came from the accretion disk in the
formation of the sun
um and uh it's more or less in a plane i
mean something like pluto is a bit out
of the plane and there are some other
things that are a bit out of the plane
but more or less all the planets are
lined up in the so-called plane of the
ecliptic
it's called the plane of the ecliptic
because that's the angle at which
eclipses happen because that's the angle
relative to the earth that's the angle
that the sun is
is that we're orbiting the sun at so to
speak
um
let's see there's a there's a comment
here about fractal patterns and
receiving signals yeah that's a
complicated story so one of the issues
with an antenna
is that
you
when you generate radio
it's usually the radio signal it's
usually at a certain frequency
like cell phones they might be in the
two gigahertz band the five gigahertz
band that means that the electron is
going up and down two gigahertz means
the electron is going up and down two
billion times a second
um and uh and that's um and so
there's one of the questions is
if you have like if you have your phone
and you've got like in the us
you might have an att phone or you might
have a verizon phone it's like why do
you need a different physical phone to
deal with different
uh a different cell phone carrier well
the answer is that the electromagnetic
spectrum
is broken up into okay you get the
2.2174
gigahertz band you get the
2.283 gigahertz band and so on and so
the radio spectrum is broken into these
very small slices
um it's just like you know it in the
case where you have a broadcast radio
station you might say um you know this
is and they're well usually given their
i think it's a rule in the an fcc rule
that they have to say every so often
they have to say we're you know kzwx
uh 97.4
megahertz or whatever that's so that
means that they have been allocated a
frequency of let's say 97 megahertz
which would be 97 million
uh
sort of oscillations of electron per
second
um
and uh so different
in order to in order that you can have
these these different uh many different
radio stations many different cell
phones operating you you kind of slice
up the spectrum and say you get this
particular frequency range you get this
other frequency range
footnote in
uh even in 3g cellular naphthalene um
the uh that actually isn't how it works
it's more complicated than that it isn't
that every cell phone gets a particular
slice of frequency that's so-called code
division multiplexing is what's commonly
used there i think um in which it's a
slightly more complicated story which i
can explain and in 5g it's it's yet more
complicated again
and um it isn't it isn't really the case
that you get allocated each each phone
gets allocated a certain frequency but
it is the case that a phone carrier will
get allocated a certain range of
frequencies
and so when you have a phone that's like
a you know a a um
an att phone or something it's good for
certain it the certain frequencies that
att bought
and that it has an antenna operating at
those frequencies
so i actually have not really paid
attention to how this evolves maybe
maybe that's not true anymore you have
to get a new phone for a different
carrier i think maybe you don't because
i think i've changed sim cards recently
and that hasn't happened now but it used
to be the case and the reason it used to
be the case is because it'll be a
different frequency and there will be a
different antenna that you would make
with a different size and so on to deal
with that different frequency now one of
the questions is can you make an
all-purpose antenna can you make an
antenna will just work for any frequency
and and the answer is it's kind of
difficult
um it's kind of like a lot of things
have a certain resonant frequency so for
example if you say
i've got well like like a string
on a and you bow the string the string
will vibrate with a certain
characteristic frequency if you change
the length of the string it will vibrate
with a different characteristic
frequency
and so it is with antennas that you can
typically have sort of these different
sizes of antennas will have different uh
roughly resonant frequencies it's much
more complicated than this the the
antenna design is an art and you see
lots of lots of books of things of
different shaped antennas and you get
all these uh what are they called log
linear antennas i think maybe that have
they're all these different shapes and
antennas that people have made up that
have certain characteristics that are
particularly optimized for certain
freight frequencies ranges of
frequencies and so on i mean like for
example one had uh uh you know someone
could have just an antenna that's like
um sometimes an old-fashioned car
antenna i haven't seen one of these for
a long time
um that's just uh i think before whip
antennas which are just like a straight
piece of wire that just goes straight up
of a certain length
um i know like the the sat phone that i
have has an antenna that you pull up and
it's just a straight linear antenna um
and
then
the um
uh there are different shaped antennas
like old-fashioned televisions
back in the day when there was some
oh gosh these are so-called uh vhf
antennas uh they used to be look like um
used to have a a big it used to be like
one of those um
uh those things you see from from fishes
that have um
these funny um uh sort of it's a big
straight piece and then little sort of
ribbing coming out of each side a whole
sequence of little things sort of like
little ribs coming out of each side that
was another kind of shape of antennas
um the uh
so there are there's a whole sort of zoo
of different kinds of antenna shapes and
people regularly try and you know evolve
different antenna shapes that's been a
thing people have tried to do
uh with some success sort of discover a
new antenna shape just like you've been
you know biological organisms can
discover a new uh a new biological form
that has a particular sort of fitness
so one of the things that was popular i
haven't seen these much maybe they are
um
is uh is fractal antennas actually so
here's a funny thing so so this is kind
of urban
urban tourism
okay so it's always interesting to me at
least to look at the different kinds of
devices that you see out in the world
and so if you look at a cell phone tower
you'll see these different kinds of
antennas on a cell phone tower you might
see a parabolic antenna that's a
point-to-point microwave connection
where that parabolic antenna
is just it has a signal that maybe it's
communicating with another tower and
it's just sending a signal right in a
particular direction
another thing you might see is these
these vertical
uh um sort of um
bars that are another kind of antenna
another thing you see which i think the
more modern antennas are just these
rectangular uh blocks
and and i i don't know what those are
like exactly inside
for example the antennas that are used i
have seen these ones the antennas that
are used for um
uh internet on on uh commercial planes
um they are tend to be in the tail of
the plane they're communicating usually
with a satellite and they tend to be a
rectangular thing with holes in it
um but in any case so they're different
shapes of antennas and one of the one of
the things that was done was to make an
antenna that had
essentially a nested pattern of metal
inside so a nested pattern means you you
have this thing where it's got a sort of
overall square and then it's got little
squares punched out of that and then
little squares punched out of those and
so on it's a whole sort of nested uh you
know nested inside itself uh set of
patterns and the reason that was a good
idea
is that uh if you ask sort of where is
there a thing where is there a run of
metal of a certain length what you can
get in those nested patterns is sort of
all different possible runs of lengths
of metal exist in that nested pattern
and so that means it's potentially sort
of broad spectrum antenna that works for
a range of frequencies
now talking about um
this uh
uh this kind of antenna story um
the um
uh you know one of the things that sort
of an interesting piece of that story is
so-called software radio
uh when you have an antenna what you're
doing is usually you're trying to
amplify
uh something of a particular frequency
and you do that usually by using uh sort
of analog electronics
you usually will often have something
where you have a um a thing an
oscillator with that frequency and
you'll combine
the signal that's coming in with that
oscillator signal and you'll amplify
things in that way etc
um one of the things that became
possible when computers got fast enough
when the speed of computers exceeded the
speed of of the of the individual you
know like the two gigahertz or something
that i mentioned of um uh of a signal
let's say it's a few hundred megahertz
um
that uh the computer is faster than that
and so that means that potentially you
just sort of have a wire hanging out of
your computer and the you can this you
can pick out
the the pieces of radio energy that are
sort of moving electrons in that wire
just by using software in your computer
and so there's a whole story of doing
that maybe maybe let me not
divert into that that whole story right
now of how you pick out a certain
frequency just in software um from that
wire i haven't played with the software
defined radio for a little while
actually it's been a few years but it's
kind of fun because because you can um
you can really get sort of the ambient
radio environment and you can kind of
see what's there it's kind of fun to i
did this years ago i haven't done it
recently so i can't tell you exactly
what happens recently somebody else
should do this experiment you take an
old-fashioned radio
um that has kind of a dial that allows
you just sort of step through
frequencies uh preferably not one that
has a very particular you know you press
a button to go to the next frequency um
but just you can you know just move
through it
well you say what's out there you get to
a certain frequency it'll be somebody
talking in language x you get to another
frequency it's some weird music you get
to another frequency it's other things
okay so what's actually out there
there's all kinds of weird stuff out
there there's all kinds of radio
navigation beacons that are making
beeping sounds
there's uh there's all kinds of there's
there used to be i don't know if it's
still true there used to be these
so-called numbers stations which
consisted solely of people reading off
numbers
that had something to do with the whole
bizarre
uh kind of um they were sort of coded
messages
for uh you know spies in the field and
so on maybe they started using tour on
the internet now i don't know um that
was one one of the weird things you
would find you'd find some morse code
out there uh you would find also places
where there was clearly uh radio signal
but it was sounded completely random and
that's probably data being transmitted
or encoded in certain ways and so on
it's kind of an interesting exercise to
kind of see what's out there in in the
radio spectrum from the earth if you
look at the earth as a whole
i think the most intense radio emissions
from the earth we look at the earth a
really long way away the most intense
radio emissions i believe are still the
ballistic missile early warning system
in uh in greenland
that is basically
uh it's a radar signal so radar is you
send out a radio pulse
and you see whether it gets reflected
back so if there's a if there's a plane
up there or a satellite or something
like that that's made of metal there'll
be a reflection uh the the the signal
will be reflected back
uh makes me wonder if you made the
um
i actually don't know for carbon fiber
for example whether that i think that
has a very low reflectance probably for
for radar um but in any case metal is
still the thing that lots of stuff gets
made out of and so metal um reflects
radio uh just like it reflects visible
light you know if you have a polished
you know piece of metal it'll be it'll
be shiny silvery colored or it can be
and it'll reflect back the light and it
reflects back all frequencies of
electromagnetic radiation well at least
of all all frequencies that don't sort
of penetrate the material um which which
includes some uh radio and so on uh all
frequencies down into the into the
ultraviolet and so on as soon as you get
to frequencies where the individual sort
of distances between the peaks in the
electromagnetic wave get to be smaller
than the distance between atoms kind of
all bets are off but when it isn't like
that the thing acts like a mirror
um
so
it's some
uh yeah so so that's some
um
let's see
uh
okay there's a comment here that um
uh about cell phones that some are still
carrying others unlocked yeah so that so
there's a physics question of what
antennas do they actually have in them
um
and uh
um
that's interesting so alistair's
comments that
lived in a apartment where which was
across a field from transmission towers
for an am radio station with five to six
radio towers 200 yards away and the am
station could apparently be heard on
lots of electronic devices in the house
phones answering machines etc
uh yeah no that that's a um
you know one thing is that am radio
means amplitude modulation that means
there's a certain dominant frequency a
single sort of pure tone of radio
and
the way that the signal the way that the
voice let's say
is transmitted is by changing the
amplitude changing the intensity of that
signal so as soon as you're picking up
that signal anything that is a
loudspeaker for example uh will
will start kind of
um you know you'll be able to hear the
the voice so to speak as soon as it's
kind of tuned to that frequency
the voice will come through because it's
the the whole amplitude of the signal is
is is
represents the the whole amplitude of
the radio signal represents the actual
signal that you're supposed to hear like
the voice
what got a little bit more sophisticated
with so-called frequency modulation
in which instead of varying the
amplitude you vary the frequency
slightly so you think you're a 97.5
megahertz radio station but actually
when the person says you know
says uh yeah
that is encoded in the frequency
changing slightly so it's 97.5001
megahertz for a brief moment and so on
so the reason for doing that is that
things that affect
um
if if with amplitude modulation if
there are there are things that will
change
the amount of uh there's more it's
easier to get interference with
amplitude because if you if you know if
if some rain goes in the way of of the
radio signal it will um um
uh it will get um
uh you know it will temporarily reduce
the signal and so you'll you'll hear
that in the output but it won't change
the frequency of the signal and so fm is
is more immune to noise than than am
now i think what happens in um
uh in in things like well that's
ordinary radio ordinary transmission
radio is usually fm it's usually a
different frequency band it was
allocated differently slightly higher
frequency band
um what's happened with with other forms
of radio like satellite radio is a quite
different scheme satellite radio is much
more like the internet
where there are things like packets of
of information which are encoded
digitally um digital uh that they're
there instead of instead of saying oh
it'll just be you know at this moment
you know as as you say yeah
and you know maybe increase the
frequency at the end there or something
that'll change the actual uh transmitted
radio signal instead that's encoded
digitally as it would be in you know an
mp3 mp4 whatever else any any radio any
any audio format it's encoding it
digitally as bits so for example the the
you know the it's louder might be a
different number encoded as binary bits
rather than something where there's
actually a and more intensity the
intensity is encoded in that digital
information
and so what then happens is
the um in in satellite radio for example
um the uh
the satellite is transmitting this
series of packets i think
down to um uh down to your receiver and
and for example you can encrypt those
packets
encode them then unless you have a key
you can't decode them those kinds of
things same um um and so now things get
funkier because for example with
satellite radio i actually learned this
recently but satellite radio
if you're in a city well actually you
may not have a view of the satellites
from you know if you're driving on a
city street and there's skyscrapers on
both sides
there's no satellite that your antenna
in your car can can get a signal from
there's a there's a great big skyscraper
in the way
um and so what happens in that case but
what happens is
that the satellite radio companies
aren't just sending their signals to
satellites
when there is available uh when there
are things like cell phone towers
available they're also using those kinds
of things to transmit the signals and so
in a city well there's lots of cell
phone uh
there's lots of cellphone antennas in a
city and so you have you know you're
driving down the street and while you
don't get a view of the sky to see the
satellites you do get your cell phone
works you've got there's a cell phone
antenna that you have
visibility to
and so things get funkier so for example
when you're in the middle of nowhere and
there are no skyscrapers around and
there's no cell phone service well you
can still get to the satellite because
then you've got a view of the sky now
the only place where things go very
wrong is when there are trees and
there's a terrible habit of things not
working when there's you know when it's
sort of in the middle of nowhere but
there's a tree there um then then you
can have trouble um i think the um the
thing that is kind of funky
is um
you often want to transmit the signals
with as few packets as possible and you
want to transmit um but sometimes a
packet will be received by your
satellite uh
radio receiver and the packet didn't
make it the packets have serial numbers
and it's like we got packet one two
three four oops we're missing five we
got six seven what do you do
well
uh
what happens on the internet
with protocols like tcp
is that you simply request a new copy of
that package
you know you there's a it goes back to
the server and it says oops i didn't get
that packet give me that packet again
um streaming that's sort of a difference
when you have streaming is for example
the udp protocol i think doesn't do this
which is the one usually used for
streaming it's just like here are the
packets you missed one sorry just
you know get over it so to speak but if
you want to sort of ratchet back
the um if you want to make things really
on the edge where you're where you're
transmitting things with the lowest
possible radio radio intensity and
things like this you're going to miss
some packets and the question is how do
you deal with that and so then one of
the weird things that i think is
starting to happen
is that the satellite will send you a
packet oops i missed that packet didn't
have one at that place in the in the
sequence
well actually you re-request that packet
through some uh let's say cell
phone-like network um and then that
packet is transmitted to you a different
way and all of this happens before you
hear the next word because this is all
happening you know there's a slight
delay um in the there's the satellite
what you receive from the satellite is
delayed i think that's the case if
you're if you're like watching some some
grand sporting event or something and
you can see it in real life and you're
also uh you know
hearing it through some through some
kind of satellite service i think it's
delayed a long few seconds i think um
and uh that allows one that you know if
the packets didn't arrive you can go and
request other ones and so i'm not sure
if that's been deployed yet but i think
that's something that's coming if it
hasn't hasn't happened uh already
um
okay there's there's maybe one or two
more things in there i have to go to a
day job meeting here
um
let's see is it the question here
um
uh
could we one day be able to see into the
earth's past by finding an object in
space that mirrors light left by the
earth a long time ago
i've definitely wondered about that
um
i think the answer is probably yes you
know it's a funny thing
the very earliest computers
they needed to have memory what is
memory memory is you you keep
some information and you keep it around
now today we keep it around by changing
the state of some switch in a
semiconductor in a in a memory trip but
there were things um
uh
uh mercury delay lines where we're an
early form of memory but what you would
do is you have this tube
and it would full of mercury and you
would send a sound wave through the
mercury
and you would keep recirculating that
sound wave you keep on you receive it
you amplify it you send it back through
the tube
and the point is that it took a while
you know i don't know a fraction of a
second
you know 100th of a second or something
to go through for the sound to go
through that tube and so you keep on
recirculating it around and you keep a
memory by just continual recirculation
so the question would be in this case if
there was light from the earth that went
into this mirror in space
and then you know it's out there it's
going it's going it's going for a really
long time it hits the mirror then it
comes back it's kind of like that's the
form of memory it's kind of like a
mercury delay line except it's a it's a
vacuum delay line in space
where you're where you're sending this
thing out into space and then it's
coming back
so yes i think that's conceivable the
question is what would be a thing
that would be reflective enough that
you'd get something back and of course
as there's an inverse square law of
intensity of light so the further away
you are the intensity of the light falls
off like the one over the square of the
distance just because you have a given
given uh well that's what happens for
ordinary light the laser light for
example you can at least for a while
it's it's more concentrated but forget
that it's it's roughly roughly true that
it will fall off it's as if you have you
know you're covering the surface of a
sphere with with uh you know the area of
a sphere is is
um
uh four pi r squared um
the uh that's some
uh
um and that that means as as the
if if there's a fixed amount of light
and it's spread over the sphere that
means any given
place on the sphere the amount of light
that will reach that place on the sphere
goes down like one over r squared
so um
let's see the the um uh
uh but but that means the intensity of
light will get to be very low and the
problem is if you're going to get back
that that scene of the dinosaurs or
something you better have enough photons
to be able to reconstruct that scene
it's no good to have gone below the
point where not a single photon made it
back
i do wonder
don't know the answer to this whether a
neutron star has a reflective surface i
bet that it does i bet it does
um
and so in principle
a photon from the earth
goes to the crab nebula
it's um how many light years away is
that
i don't know tens of light years away i
think
maybe thousands
i think i think i know maybe i think
it's thousands of light years away
um and so that means that the the light
from the earth
takes thousand light years thousand
years let's say to reach that that um
that neutron star and then the neutron
star is a nice you know sort of metallic
type thing
it's going to reflect that light back
now it's a little bit tricky because
it's a sphere and i guess what will be
the case is that that if it is
yeah it should be the case that that
means it will reflect it back
the way it came let me think about that
for a second yeah that's right um at
least the light that hits right on axis
will be reflected back the way it came
it's kind of like a um
is that right i think so yeah it's like
billiards hitting sort of head-on
um
the uh
um
it's uh and so
so okay so you've got you know this
light it hits the neutron star it starts
coming back to us now of course there
may be very very few photons
so
maybe i think it would be more okay so
here's an interesting question
interesting question would be if there
was something very bright like a nuclear
explosion on the earth generates lots of
photons
and some of those photons
will get all the way to this neutron
star
and then maybe
you could you could try to watch that
neutron star i mean a very tiny tiny
effect and i'm not sure uh whether
that's whether it's conceivable that you
know you kind of watch that neutron star
right at the moment when it was exactly
the right light travel time from the
time when the nuclear explosion happened
around near the earth
and um uh and see whether there's a
little you see you can detect a few
extra photons coming as a result of that
be an interesting experiment i i i'd
have to work out whether it's actually
plausible i think it will be i think
with current instrumentation i i i can't
imagine it would work whether it is in
principle possible or whether it is
beyond kind of a quantum limit of these
things i don't know uh interesting
question um it's uh but i think it is to
me that my guess would be it's totally
implausible that when we'll be able to
like uh you know get a movie of the
dinosaurs type thing by finding a
neutron star that was uh you know the
right number of millions of um of light
years away and see the reflection back
um i think that's that's not that not in
the cards now you know having said that
one of the things that's always
interesting about archaeology for
example is that over the course of time
more and more becomes reconstructable
you know i think it's some um
the uh
uh
it's something where um
uh the um
uh you know for example the fact that
dna molecules are comparatively stable
means that if somebody you know ate some
plants or meats or something and then
buried the um uh the the
the you know their plate whatever or
their or their knife can fork if they
they had those and the time whatever it
is they're eating utensils
and they still have a little trace of
dna on them then you can tell them
people have done this you know what
breed of sheep did they eat
in that you know feast
you know 3000 years ago or something
like this and the fact that it's
possible to sort of peel off that
individual molecule
and use pcr and things like that to
amplify the effect of an individual
molecule is something that's very hard
to foresee and my own guess is that when
it comes to physical materials that
there will be an awful lot more tracing
of things that becomes possible when you
have a solid surface
and things have happened to it you know
it's got little micro scratches and
things like that
there will come a time i think when it's
possible you know right now you can go
with an atomic force microscope and you
could look at each of those little
places where the atoms moved i think
it's very hard to reconstruct stuff from
that but i can imagine a time when that
reconstruction is possible and when it
becomes possible to to discuss a lot
more about sort of the the past for that
um
it's uh
um
uh yes alistair is commenting on on them
uh we might have sent a signal on a long
round trip journey and it comes back
and um uh we have no idea what it was
yeah that's a that's a very interesting
question i'm happy to talk about that
another time i wrote a piece a few years
ago about beacons for the future of our
civilization if you're going to as a
friend of mine has been doing put little
beacons on spacecraft and things and put
them on the moon and put them in in
space and in deep space and so on um you
know what can you put on them that a
future
uh
reader
would understand it all and i think it's
a philosophically very difficult
question you know what is it that you
can put there that will be
understandable even across the space of
of human archaeological time um there's
very difficult to understand a lot of
things you know what were those those
hand prints on the cave were they were
they meaningful or were they just
playful and what does that even mean or
is it you know was it a ritual that was
you know the ritual of the hands or
something which had some tremendous
significance or was it you know somebody
doing their math homework or was it what
was it one doesn't know and you know
it's very hard to to figure these things
out even across archaeological time one
one exercise that people have tried to
do
is when you bury uh nuclear waste and
it's going to be radioactive for 10 000
years
you want to put up a warning sign that
says keep out
and is understandable for 10 000 years
that's a hugely challenging problem uh
because the i think it could very well
be the case that uh you know for all we
know the handprints on those caves from
from 20 000 years ago
are exactly a keep out there's a
minotaur that lives in this cave or
something and we have no idea that's
what it meant but but somehow the you
know many hands on on you know of
different colors or something to to to
the people who lived in the cave it's
like that's obvious that means stay away
and but we don't know that anymore and
usually what happens with these kinds of
chains of meaning
is that
unless we can
identify unless we can project things we
do today back into what we see there
it's really hard to have a
a kind of an understanding meaning and
unless unless there's sort of a thread
of constant activity like unless there's
a you know artisans who've been making
that kind of thing
forever and ever you know the kippus of
of of uh peru and so what were they it's
like you know if there have been a
continuous chain of artisans making
those things across across 500 years or
or more one would probably have a better
understanding of what those things
actually are and what they're for
similarly people have been making
stonehenge like monuments
you know continuously for for thousands
of years we would kind of know oh yeah
that's a that's a this kind of thing
because after all we make one just like
that today but without that kind of
chain of connection it's really hard to
know this anyway interesting topic
um and uh
i need to go but thanks for joining me
and um uh look forward to doing this
again um next week and thanks for lots
of interesting questions
today was i guess radio day
and
yeah
thanks and